what's going on everybody welcome to
part three of our playing air hockey
with a robotic arm series in the last
video we worked on some color filtering
to at least hopefully find mostly the
puck but we noticed that we were finding
quite a few other things and then also
having a hard time always finding the
puck depending on where it was on the
board in this video what I'd like to
cover is the the changes that I would
make here to better detect the puck also
to get rid of the edges around the game
board and actually learn a new function
that exists in CV I don't know when it
came about but it's super useful and
then also get the center of the puck
itself so and then also in sort of
theory filter out some of the outlier
detection that we get so let's get
started so first of all right now I
don't have the thing running whenever
we're ready to watch the puck move
around or whatever I'll go ahead and run
it
otherwise it's like this horrible fan
noise in the background so anyways let
me just run the script real quick just
so we can see where we are so we can see
that yeah we've got the puck but we've
got some stuff going on around and for
whatever reason when the puck was
getting over here it was kind of causing
trouble
so I'm actually gonna change how we're
detecting the puck and the thresholds
like a priority the same but I'm
actually just going to copy and paste
over the values that I'm gonna go with
so from puck to the red
paste in so this is just the lower read
value the upper read value and then I
went back to the Gaussian blur and then
this is the threshold that I'm using
something just run that real quick make
sure what image Pro oh right right right
right right okay so so there are some
other changes that we're gonna make so
let me go ahead and make those other
changes as well so I part of me doesn't
want to make them just yet though do I
have is that the only I think that's the
only call for image crop yeah so we'll
just pass frame and frame for now and
then I'm gonna forget to fix that later
most likely anyway okay so this actually
looks very similar to the one that we
had before where we were finding a lot
of stuff around the edge but the edge
here in this case is off of the playing
field at the plane board anyways so we
actually could just trim those away now
in the past to select or region of
interest I would have just kind of
manually done it but this of course
causes trouble depending on if the board
moves or whatever so be nice to be able
to do this every time uniquely and I
stumbled upon this new function this
literally select ROI so before I forget
let me just edit undo also just want to
say all of the text you know the sample
code I will put up also for since I know
a lot of people first of all buying the
expensive robotic arm but then not
everyone's gonna buy an air hockey table
and all that and if you still want to
take part what I'm gonna do is not only
while I upload the the image that you
could use but also I'll uploads a short
video clip basically that way you can
also detect the puck and all that kind
of stuff in a video clip form I'm gonna
put everything up on both Python
programming and net but also I'll have
everything on a github I probably won't
do the github until we're a little
further along it's kind of silly for me
to put it up and then people start
making changes but it's like well I'm
already beyond that point I've probably
made the same changes or something like
that so anyways
I probably won't have the official
github up for a little bit but at least
to start I'd like to at least have some
examples of at least how you can read in
the video feed and an image and all that
so people can still take part without
having to buy all this stuff so anyways
the next thing yes so image crops so
what we're going to do is basically
after we've done the setting of our
resolution what I'm going to go ahead
and use for I in range 15 all we're
going to do here is just iterate through
and in fact I'm just gonna say cap
doggery we're just gonna iterate through
some frames because for whatever reason
every time you first start in CV it
actually it's almost like it fades in so
it's like black and then it slowly fades
into the camera so so we don't really
want it it's kind of hard to select your
region of interest when that's doing
that so anyway
you'll see what I mean in a minute I'll
show you if I recall anyway so then
we're going to do select find the region
of interest so we're gonna say CV to dot
select ROI and then we select the ROI
ROI on a frame so in fact we will need
to do this in frame you just can't read
so now what that does for us actually
super cool so what comes up first is
this ROI selector and then you basically
you'll just click and drag the region of
interest that you're interested in and
you're good and then once you're happy I
think you can hit enter space or
something else and I don't know but
anyways you can enter and then it goes
we hit an error but I'm pretty sure yeah
it's cuz the image crop and that's fine
so then once you get that region of
interest this just gives you that region
so basically it'll it gives you the you
know the coordinates of that region of
interest so then you would want to apply
those coordinates to your frame so I'm
just gonna copy and paste that in but
basically it's just it slices it's
you're just slicing the frame okay so
then we crop the image then we're going
to convert it as we did before and in
fact HSV will now
done against image crop okay crop good
good good good good I just want to make
sure we're not doing anything with that
frame anymore no we are not so now if we
run that again we can run you know you
select the region that you're interested
in hit enter and I'm not happy with how
that did that why would it do that hmm
it's as if it why would it do that to me
I appreciate it brother try to compare
it to what I know works possible well
let's probably this resize let's try it
I don't really want to do that that's
probably what was causing our trouble
actually let me try that one more time
cool okay so now that looks a lot more
like what we're looking for you can't
fully tell but basically you can see the
pucks near the top and in our final
screen that's where the puck is you can
see we've got a little bit of flicker or
red over here but I'll show you what I'm
gonna do to get rid of that here in a
second so everything looks pretty good
and now what we'd want to do is if we
are going to control the arm we need to
know where that puck actually is so what
I'm gonna do is exit out of here
and I'm gonna come back down here to
where we've got these like where clauses
and again I'm gonna I think we'll just
copy and paste the code that I've
written here don't really see why we'd
want to write it all out so paste and
I'm going to get rid of that so the exes
are here the Y's are here and actually
I'm pretty confident those are flipped I
think we'll have to flip those later I
think I'm just gonna flip it right
now I'm I'm pretty confident it's
actually why than X we'll see that later
on but anyways so now we're just getting
all the X values so the X pixel
locations then what I want to do is
calculate the standard deviation and
then what I'd like to do is basically
we're gonna come down here and get the
initial average of all of the X's
whatever that initial average is so when
you have that big old blob and they've
got a couple little X's over here what
we're gonna then say is now once we
figure out what that initial average is
and what the standard deviation is what
I'm doing down here is basically
iterating over all of the X's and asking
we're gonna say it's X for X in X's if X
is less than or equal to the initial
average plus the standard deviation or X
is greater than or equal to that initial
average minus the standard deviation if
it is outside of those bounds then we're
gonna go ahead and say that it's an
outlier and we throw it out once we've
done that then we're gonna calculate the
true average the X average and the y
average and then you have a pixel well
yeah sort of a pixel location we've done
a lot of trimming and stuff like that
but then you have an actual location for
the thing that we're attempting to track
and we're just gonna print those out now
so now I'm gonna do is just run this one
more time and we'll select the region of
interest and then we run and so as you
can see here we've got x and y are both
is that true I'm gonna see X oh these
are the so the sixes and sevens that
you're seeing those are these standard
deviations so the other thing you could
plausibly do is if standard deviation is
like 15 or 18 or whatever if the
standard deviation is more than the
standard deviation is usually all right
you could use that logically to your
advantage to know who maybe we don't go
based on whatever
number we're seeing now so basically the
idea is once you know where the puck is
you can always know where the arms
position is we can always pull the arm
to figure out where the arm is so then
what we can do is we can position the
arm based on where the pucks position is
in terms of x and y now with OpenCV I
don't think you can see my mouse weird
sometimes you can see my mouse and
sometime you can anyways where our mouth
is right now in theory that's X is zero
Y is zero and then it goes X out like
this and then Y goes out downward
unfortunately you can't always see my
mouse but anyways that's the way it
works so yeah right here is where zero
zero is actually so now what I'd like to
do is I guess we can I kind of want to I
just want to comment out the standard
deviation part just so we can see as the
puck moves I don't like this one let's
redraw that one the camera also needs to
be tilted slightly but that's okay we're
just kind of debugging right now anyways
okay so you can see here the X is 500
the Y is 17 ish or so and that appears
to be correct and then now what I'm
gonna do is I'm going to turn it on and
kind of bump the puck and we can watch
okay so everything looks to be in order
the puck appears to be tracking pretty
darn well we appear to be tracking the
actual center point of the puck pretty
well as well so now what we're ready to
do is move on to the next part which is
moving the arm in conjunction with the
puck and also hopefully hitting the puck
so the idea here in this case I just
have the one arm I'd love to get a
second arm we'll see about that
and so for now I'm actually just hitting
it to the end and you can't quite see it
you can sort of see it on the video
actually this part right here that I'm
going around is actually just a piece of
cardboard I stuck in the goal box so
anytime it comes over here and actually
hits this area it's actually it just
bounces off the cardboard and I've done
the same thing on the other side so
there's no way the pucks going anywhere
but later on what I can do is I can
actually color this a color that doesn't
yet exist we could go with like a blue
for example or some other color too and
basically once you color that basically
if the puck is to hit it we could say oh
that was a score and we can use that to
reinforce certain behaviors in the model
so it can actually train itself later on
anyway that is all for now as always if
you've got questions comments concerns
whatever feel free to leave them below
if you want to support the content hit
the Python program internet so lash so
work if you've got ideas for improvement
have I made some mistakes I'm sure I
have feel free to post them below
hopefully by the time you're watching
this so at least be a slight github up
with at least some samples and stuff
like that in it there won't be a
finished product and we'll be continuing
to work on this most likely by the time
this this video comes up but anyways
feel free to submit your ideas or help
out or any way you can so anyways I will
see you in the next video